and his passing in these high screen  roles as well Dillard has it down by two  here come the Blazers later with the  till for the topic it's Clarke by Mitch  Hamilton's and authority and George  [Music]  the couch by Paul George what is there  going to give a technical tuner kitch  that's going to be his second because he  picked up a technical earlier with that  skirmish with Westbrook yes he and it  looked like the official ed Malloy  signal a technical for Paul George and  Newark it's who have gotten fouled on  the offensive rebound here without that  that might have been it  here instead by Marrakesh which wasn't  calm there's the head but it kind of  looks like offensive interference there  by Turkish  [Applause]  I love this time of year here partner oh  this is good  this is absolutely fabulous time of year  for basket particular right watch yep  that bug and ed Malloy Shawn well he's  going to be kicked out